[Music]  Caty home and daughter Suri Cruise take  Paris Fashion Week she's a sophisticated  little girl and and magical we're sure  sophisticated Suri would have fit right  in at Dior's runway show on Monday as  model strutted down the catwalk for the  designers autumn winter hot couture  collection  [Music]  while the 38 year old actress got glam  and stepped out without her 12 year old  mini-me for Dior chic unveiling the  mother-daughter duo enjoyed a stroll  around Paris the day before in their own  fashion-forward looks here's the pair  looking too cute in coordinating floral  ensembles and ballet flats well we can't  get over how fast Surrey is growing up  and how much she favors her stunning  mama she makes every day great and  awesome and better  [Music]  [Applause]